بالموت تقذفهم
وبدمار ابناء غزه تحت قصف اسرائيل لاكثر
من اسبوع هذا بعض مما تفعله الغارات
الاسرائيليه والقصف البري والبحري
بالقطاع احياء كامله تسوى بالارض وعائلات
باكملها تباد بمئات تال الالفين يعد
الغزيون
شهدائهم وبالف
صبيهم معظمهم من النساء والاطفال غصت بهم
المستشفيات التي تتلاحق منها نداءات
الاستغاثه ومطالب بارسال مساعدات ووفود
طبيه مع ذلك كله لم تذع مشافي القطاع
لاوامر الاخلاء القصري المتكرره من جيش
الاحتلال وتلك انذارات تتعالى دعوات دوليه
لوقفها لم
تتوقف توقف استهداف المرافق الصحيه
والطواقم الطبيه كما لم تحيد حتى مدارس
الاونروا التي تؤوي نازحين
بالقطاع والقطاع مقطوعه عنه المياه
والكهرباء والغذاء والدواء ان لم يكن هذا
عقابا جماعيا فما عساه
يسمى مع تردي الوضع الانساني جراء القصف
الاسرائيلي يقول برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
ان مخزونه في القطاع يشارف على النفاد وان
مساعدات انسانيه تكفي لاطعام نحو مليون
و300 الف شخص تتكدس على الحدود المصريه مع
غزه غزه التي يقول جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان عمليات الاخلاء من شمالها
مستمره بمب ما زال الساسه والقاده
العسكريون في التل ابيب يتواعدون قطاع غزه
بهجوم بري واسع لا قبل لها به يجتث
المقاومه يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
استكمل حشده للعمليه قرب ما يعرف بغلا في
غزه اما والله وقد هزمنا في عقر كيانكم
فما ظنكم بنا وقد اتيتم الينا
باقدام انا والله قد اعددنا لكم رجالا
يحبون القتل في سبيل الله كما انتم تحبون
الحياه فاهلا وسهلا بكم في رحاب الجحيم
الاستعداد لصد اي عدوان محتمل لا ينفي فعل
المبادره لا تكتفي المقاومه ببيان ما
ينتظر قوات الاحتلال البريه ان هي حاولت
التوغل في غزه فثبات القطاع يقابل هناك
رعبا في تل ابيب وعسقلان
وسديت باتجاه ثلاثتها اطلقت كتائب القسام
دفعات جديده من الصواريخ والقذائف ردا على
استهداف المدنيين في
غزه هنا يوثق عضو الكنيسه الاسرائيلي داني
دانون لحظه سقوط صاروخ على سديروت خلال
زيارته
للمنطقه قد تكون القبه الحديديه اعترضت
بعضا من صواريخ المقاومه غير ان استمرار
انهارها على العمق الاسرائيلي سيزيد حتما
من حرج سلطات الاحتلال وجيشها فكلهم يعلم
ان ثمه الطوفان
وثمه ما
بعده